hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2023 US championships
we're very pleased to have in studio our
curator from the World Chess Hall of
Fame
Emily all red sorry thank you for having
me on the broadcast it's been brilliant
and gosh I feel like I've known you for
so many years and the exhibits over the
years they come flooding to my to to
mine what was your favorite um I have a
lot of favorites some of the ones that
hold a special place in my heart are the
ones where we explore the history of
chest sets so one that we had a few
years ago was called ponds and passports
and that's where we showed chess sets
from our collection that were from all
around the world but we've also worked
with a lot of really cool collectors
like John crumiller and that's we've
done some really wonderful shows with
him too I know I love those old sets but
we're here to talk about today's exhibit
TS Elliot yes so we have an exhibit
right now it's called TS Elliot a game
of chess and it explores the connections
between one of St Lewis's best known
writers uh TS Elliott and um our
favorite game chess uh he included chess
as a theme in some of his uh in some of
his poetry and he is a chess player
himself exactly and Emily can you tell
us a little bit more about Elliot and St
Louis and the location of uh the World
Chess Hall of Fame yeah so Elliot grew
up in St Louis um and after he left St
Louis his family moved to a home that's
in St Louis's central western
neighborhood which is where we're
located um the World Chess Hall of Fame
wow so it's amazing to actually have the
exhibition there very close to his uh
place yes yeah it's a really wonderful
connection between our show and his
family um his mother also was very
involved with a social club um that's
located not too far from the World Chess
Hall of Fame the link auditor torium
perfect and can you tell us a little bit
more specifically about how Elliot
Incorporated chess into his poetry yes
so the show is mainly focused on his
poem The Wasteland and um in that poem
there's one section called a game of
chess so there the poem explores all
sorts of themes from um you know
relationships which a game of chess does
um to the Fallout of World War I um and
a game of chess he's talking
about the relationship he had with his
wife um whom he married after not
knowing for very long and quickly had
difficulties in the relationship and so
he's using the game of chess kind of as
to talk about how in relationships you
might try to make a move to have the
advantage and things like
that but we I can't believe that you
know you try to get the upper hand in
the chess game and in a relationship as
well yeah um but we have some
artifacts um either on view in person
where you can see um some of the books
that he included references to in the
poem um there's some there's some chess
poetry that we have in the collection
and we have that on view but then we
also have photos of his own chess set
that people can check out his chess
books and um even a little notebook that
his father put together of Chess columns
he'd cut them out and paste them in this
little uh this little book so I I have
to say I'm always so amazed how you all
at the hall of fame know so much about
chess players and about like people
related to chess and chess culture
because we like titled Players let's say
we know about Chess and chess games but
specifically about the players I'm
always amazed every time I'm there I I
learn something new me too Emily thank
you so much for joining us and tell tell
everybody where they can go in the
Central West End uh to visit your
exhibits yeah so we're located just
across the street from the chess club
and you can learn more about our
exhibitions if you're not able to make
it to St Louis by going to World Chess
h.org again Emily thank you so much
thank thank you thank you for being here
with us and our pairings for this uh
round